how are there still monkeys
if we came from there
I mean I'd be good for the right wing
media as well actually yeah you should
follow up yeah you should open for
Oliver I believe in Jesus
[Laughter]
[Music]
so what do we think about my new glasses
dude I love your new glasses do you yeah
do you do you like my eyeglasses come on
now do you do your lucky
glass
come on a song you'd listen to that an
eye doctor would play for kids I like
your new glasses but do you like
my new hat
look down do you do you like my new hat
so we can come on now do you do you like
my new hat okay I'm seeing in
um what do you think
I mean honestly it looks right with the
dangly earring oh cool but it's not a
good hat watch your mouth on your phone
I got it at 7-Eleven dude oh that's
weird you didn't get it at a high
fashion place uh dude they have really
good hats at 7-Eleven there's a third
hat I've bought at 7-Eleven and let me
tell you too I know it's American but it
was definitely in a Mexican neighborhood
what do you mean it was oh oh right
oh yeah there you go I drove by a place
that was selling on display
construction worker vests that are were
like reflective and lingerie and I go
like this oh this must be the Mexican
neighborhood why I don't even know what
there's just it just I don't either but
it's something that is a feeling and you
know what's up did we already been going
for 11 minutes no it's hours dude oh
um but yeah that's pretty that isn't
that but that is right if you think
about it like it's a Mexican
neighborhood if they're doing it what
was it though I mean that's the oh I
don't even know I just assumed it I
don't know so you don't know I think it
probably was
but it's not racist okay so now
see now okay I see yes yes yes yes
because Mexicans will go like oh damn I
need that for work and damn that's
[__] hot remember the story I had
about uh the Tweety Bird with the uh
call the cops I'll have sex with them I
think I was talking about no yeah here
the shirt I drove by the storefront I
had this shirt I wanted oh I didn't tell
you what is it called the cops thing the
thing on it the shirt I didn't even
describe the shirt because I was like I
don't want anybody to buy it so
everybody forget what it's not there
anymore right no it wasn't there when I
go by and I haven't I've looked online
I've Googled it like many many times you
can't find it well this is good describe
what the shirt is because people will
find it and send you the link
impress me by finding it so I'll
describe it it's it's a black shirt with
Tweety Bird on it so far it's horrible
no it's great it's like a big baggy
shirt big or like an oversized shirt
couldn't be booty bird no I would
already wear it first of all but okay is
the Tweety Bird embroidered on or is it
no it's like cheaply like laminated on
her however I don't know what you call
that when you make it uh whatever yeah I
don't know what's worse uh and and the
quote the thing the Tweety Bird was
saying it had like a like a
gangster woman like thing in its hair
like it was like being a not a vato it's
a one the shirt's a one what is that for
oh yeah okay anyway Chola Chola thank
you a chola Tweety Bird yeah it was like
decked out stuff right no that's a 10
out of ten already no it's a one dude uh
that's something I'm forgetting I'm
paraphrasing because I don't remember
exactly but it was like it was it was
basically threatening saying like go
ahead and call the cops
I can't wait to have sex with them like
call the cops and I'll have sex with
them that was the quote that the tweet
it didn't make sense though like the
reason I'm saying it wrong is because it
was wrong and that was the best part of
the shirt I
what that's scary you didn't know how to
pull it up on the thing
I gotta give it to him I don't have a
killer gotcha okay cool okay anyway I'm
very excited and if it's not the right
one I'm very upset well you think
there's two no no I think that like that
somebody just randomly made it you know
I mean I don't think there was these
were made and mass you know what I'm
saying
oh it was just one in that store yeah
no there's one there's two sure you know
that you know that saying it's a good
theory so bring it up so I wonder why
it's not up so bring it up why would it
not be up yet it's not up this podcast
yeah no I know but I tried another
Google what's Anthony doing what is he
doing well I didn't find it uh well
somebody did yeah so why is it not up
the fact that it was found and this
half-assed podcast dude isn't good it's
not good
it's not what did you tweet he says
because of the Tweety bird is on it he
got confused what a [__] we love you
though we love you
I have no way of sending it to you how
you need to [__] find it yourself but
how does he have no way of sending it
why can't you
telling the words you Googled that's
that's gonna be funny Bird t-shirt
called cops is what that's good that's
good
thank you what do we got here 3D Bird
t-shirt cops I wonder if something
that's never been Googled I guess I
never Googled that
oh
no this is the one you're in what does
it say nope you clicked the wrong one
click the black one he said it was black
pick the one that's black that's the
right one t-shirt dude oh my God
okay [__] call the cops I'll have sex
with them
[Laughter]
go to the T-shirt I kind of like that
sweatshirt one dude that's incredible
sleeves dude somebody buy me that that
actually is the [__] sickest shirt
you're right dude once I saw it that's a
that's a nine shirt that's different
yeah see that's the thing why are there
different colorways dude it's so popular
it's popping off
okay [__] call the cops in Swedish I
gotta get that I want one too let's
bring the shirt of the pot like the
official pod go to go to go up go go to
did they have lard that's good dude
get two XL yeah yeah and charge it to
the the thing this is unreal charge it
to the game yeah okay
um that's incredible dude all right good
so sad wow I'm really happy right now
okay [__] call the cops Tweety Bird
sure you know
awful does uh Disney get paid for that
is it Disney no it's totally not no no
not sanctioned yeah all the cops I'll
have sex with them you know why I think
it was taken down maybe because it's
like oh people at Disney obviously or
yeah it's not even Disney that's Looney
Tunes is that I don't know anyway these
large corporations obviously scour the
internet have legal teams that take this
[__] down you know I mean like with a
good reason there's a million of these
right here right they're saying I'm
telling you though I I actually Googled
it extensively when I looked and it was
obviously I would have found it you know
I mean it just didn't come up wow I feel
like maybe you didn't your Googling
skills aren't there I mean maybe but
that seems weird even if who like who
has bad Googling skills you want the Hat
yeah I want to see how we're looking to
have I look pretty bad in a hat
dude I realize how big my head is it's
on the biggest setting my head the size
of you my head just give me an Excel two
inches that's the move yeah
um for that
he's two inches dude I'm two inches wide
two inches long two inches tall yeah
um I'm saying [__]
oh yeah there we go there we go wow I
mean no no so that's 0.2 inches I'm two
inches tall and my [__] is 0.2 inches
whoa that's really small it's smaller
than a [__] that's small
so uh all right yeah we got to get those
shirts and put it on the show what's
that one what do you think
it's a good colorway too yeah that's a
good well you like purple what do you
think who do you think you are that
one's not as good obviously the attitude
isn't the attitude isn't right the thing
is there's a lot of the Tweety Bird with
Attitude thing that was it what was a
thing that was a section by them yeah it
was like oh okay yeah yeah and it was
like the Tasmanian devil was like that
too and they were just like
yeah that's so good oh there's other
ones
come on bro what what okay don't Google
Google called Tweety bird called no
Google
call the Cox call the cops I'll have sex
with them that must be a thing oh maybe
yeah because that this is insane that
there's a bunch of different sometimes
it's like that it's like
shirts just have like people in other
countries write them in English it's got
to be from like What's that show on HBO
it's got to be like from that with the
two Australian guys or something New
Zealand guys oh no it's just yeah it's
just a thing I thought maybe from a show
you know I'd be wearing and somebody's
like hey [__] Michael Scott I'm like
I got an office shirt no that would be
bad yeah dude what if we found out it
was from like oh God like Michael Scott
would wear something like that and I
think it's funny and then yeah too bad
that show's already off the air now they
can't do it so we're in the clear we're
in the clear all right cool so or if
it's like a sunny Philadelphia I do
think that is a funny show but yeah this
is so weird how there's so many of these
I can't believe
I must have I must have I'm ashamed I'm
frankly I'm ashamed yeah but I'm really
happy though too all right well we got
that black shirt can't wait to wear that
I gotta be honest with you I'm gonna
wear it for my shows coming up in Little
Rock Arkansas and also Nashville I will
be in Nashville and Little Rock Arkansas
and then I have a uh run
I have a run in Canada crystallia.com
Cleveland Pittsburgh uh Philadelphia
Detroit I'm gonna be in a whole mess of
slew of different places uh yeah let's
look go ahead hit tour uh uh uh yeah
keep it moving Montreal keep moving uh
Orlando Florida Fort Myers for some
reason Richmond Virginia and Baltimore
which are the two I always forget about
Richmond Virginia Richmond north of
Richmond dude is it North do you know
about this oh what's that
you're good we can talk about it after
okay and then we go to uh if you want to
leave a
what do you call it a uh a thing uh well
first of all patreon.com Lifeline luxury
is popping off our patreons keep getting
bigger and bigger Lifeline luxury is a
blast we don't give advice we just
[__] talk about each other laughing
have a good time we talk about childhood
stuff we talk about things going on in
the news we have a blast having a good
time every note is the same here so
um and we have uh two at least two
episodes a month uh that are longer than
a half an hour but they're great they're
popping off we've been doing like three
a month at least uh so yeah and then if
you have a thing uh if you want to leave
a message on the hotline or go to watch
lifeline.com if you have a question we
love the follow-up questions uh send us
videos uh describing a situation with
the weirdo in your life we want to hear
about the weirdos in your life and then
we also have a one-on-one advice
sessions with mattelier at matalia.com
you can go get that and then the merch
is obviously so uh
lifelinemarch.commerch.com so what is
North Virginia North uh North what is it
North what is West Virginia Alec uh no
um okay so Richmond north of Richmond I
can't believe you don't know this it's
so maybe I'd love to know this okay it's
that song that went super viral with Mr
Redbeard guy Oliver Anthony or whatever
his name is it's this that like right
wing oh oh the new song that works yeah
yeah it's great yeah that sounds great
okay well you said you didn't know what
it was and I'm here
that's the name of the song North
rich men north of Richmond is the name
of oh it is which is a good title for a
song title for anything yeah
so that's it what's cool about this guy
I don't want to have any commentary
about the song the song's been
pundited to death dude everybody's got
it it's a really good song Here's the
thing though all anyone wants to talk
about with the song is the politics I
know and not outside of what the song is
talk about if the song's good or bad
that's way more interesting I don't care
about the politics
the thing that happened is it caught
fire with right-wing media yeah I
understand then people on the left had
to be like oh but it's this I know
you're right when people have to be like
oh but I love it because it's this it's
the same thing it is like nobody gets to
have an opinion because everybody's got
to be like Oh I'm affiliated with this
Camp it's this isn't a song baby it's
the same thing as the movie with the
[__] children of Freedom or whatever
the hell freedom but this sound of
freedom
but that movie was a a right wing enter
not right I understand but like an
Enterprise but hold on a second this
guy's just putting a song no no yes no
he had a political idea it's but dude so
does like oh and I love the song so does
Leadbelly he's not like a political
singer though he writes songs that have
to do with like in this case living now
in the where he lives and how much it
sucks and the people I don't know though
he knows he wanted to well hold on this
hold on though this song got so popular
because it's good it it if it was bad it
wouldn't have caught fire like this
politically even you're you're partially
right but the truth of the matter is no
song blows up that fast without an
enormous push from somewhere and the
push was explicitly whatever it's worth
right wing media that's all that's this
is Rogan posted it though he's not right
wing he's he's made after the big push
was made okay well I don't mean like it
was like a conspiracy no no I know that
I know that I just mean like people on
the right really it really resonated
with them and they really have taken to
it like it's an Anthem it's all I'm
saying with him though right he's an
apolitical person who's just making
music he is he's not like a an overly
right-wing person not no he's just
literally a guy yeah they made it seem
like he is though yeah no but he's not
yeah right
but I found out later right he's like
he I guess he's gotten record offers and
he's like declining all of them it's
like I don't want to do any of this
stuff and people are shocked when they
make me these offers and I say no but
that's not well I don't even think I'm
not gonna be musician I don't want to do
it I never planned on doing it I'm sure
he will because how could he not the guy
is so talented the first four songs on
the Billboard 100 are all his right now
three four times going back in time he
like knocked Jason Aldean's song off the
top of the chart incredible by himself I
wonder what number I would be in the top
100 if I came out with a song you
wouldn't be on the top 100. if I really
gave it a real go a college try
like just I don't know what I would say
what's the song though it doesn't matter
who's doing it obviously this guy came
out of nowhere what's the song about
[Music]
the evolution and you know some time no
that's good no that was good it's about
Evolution that's cool what about
Evolution how are there still monkeys
if we came from there
I mean that'd be good for the right wing
media as well actually so you should
follow up yeah you should open for
Oliver I believe in Jesus
hahaha
wow oh they're still monkeys gospel song
how are there still monkeys how are they
still monkeys it's the dumbest argument
against them you know
how is it how but it's like so we
evolved from monkeys hmm kinda makes you
think
just go to the zoo and get back to me
wow I believe in Jesus
honestly that's the song I would listen
to and we all know it
with your Tweety Bird shirt I love
gospel music ah all right well I think
that's a great I think that'd be great
song I think I could if I I think I
should make a song like that some
producer get at me I gotta make a song
like that where I'm singing and but it
has to be good though it can't be that I
want good production what genre of music
is it gonna be like that pop oh like
okay but a radio hit yeah a radio I'm
going for it okay
okay well see who comes in who I know
don't hit me up if you got ten thousand
followers I'm talking about I need the
guy who worked with Pharrell or
something like you want like Timberland
or something like that yeah buddy big
yeah okay
so let's go for uh Rick Rick
rubin's might not do that one uh all
right so here we go let's do a uh an
advice I just uh needed to acknowledge
the conversation around women needing to
pop pimples oh yeah and I just want to
say as a woman
that is [__] disgusting thank you
Let's Get Married thank you yeah thank
you well I mean I've never met a woman
that does it there are some out there
that are like you and this is proof so
thanks for letting us that's cool uh I I
really wonder how her life made her feel
that way because I would find at base
women just like to do that that that's
their that's their taking care of you
kind of nurturing yeah but even if
that's true she was obviously you know
had a rough childhood but even like you
know even when we say like oh men are
like this women are like this that's
true but like in a 60 40 way not like in
a 98 to two her dad died early
what her dad probably died early or
something who hers she had a rough
childhood I mean worst psychologist you
know did your dad die early all the
first five minutes to say one thing
about pimples and then Chris as a
psychiatrist says yeah her dad your dad
probably died early
your dad's no longer with us right he
died early
no he's great he's married to my mom
okay let's get to the bottom of this
thing okay let's get to the bottom why
you're lying to me about your father
he'll die soon
um
uh yeah well okay I I I yeah that was
good thank you for the thought thank you
for that that is very good production
very good producer job way better than
Anthony couldn't do the thing Anthony
literally couldn't even use the keyboard
yep type letters onto it and not only
that he wasn't even doing any letters he
was it was Zero things on and he was
just he was literally he was literally
sitting there like shaking Frozen like a
deer in headlights didn't know what to
do he was almost cried but he
almost cried I did
oh that's not a movie tin and Tina it's
called tin and Tina oh it is yeah oh
what is that it's a [__] Spanish film
but what is it a horror movie about two
about twins that are adopted cool sounds
good I like this sounds Japanese frankly
yeah it does sound Japanese but it's
Spanish because I said and I said that I
know I'm not saying it is Japanese I'm
saying that I gotta be honest he sounds
Japanese it's not very good oh okay well
then let's not talk about it I mean it
had a lot of Promise a lot of Promise
the first half was great and then I was
like all right it's the whole thing when
the [__] movies are like you know
look this is a common thing with horror
movies and you kind of have to give
horror movies the benefit of the doubt
when you're like you know you're like
why are they still in the house yeah
they wouldn't be you
little bit of that in a horror movie
yeah there was too much of that in this
one too much of that they [__]
murdered the family dog and they're like
well they're
they're 11. oh yeah
you'd be sent to yeah yeah yeah it's too
much but if if a kid that I adopted
killed my dog I would just kill the kid
it'd be a whole mess you know
be such a mess I'd be like front page
headlines the trial of the year you know
matalia kills adopted children because
they killed this kid with that hat on
the front page American Matt Dalia yeah
all right
um all right another one picture of him
set design we're hearing Chiang Mai on
our honeymoon oh cool a whole lot of
like
sweaty Street needs and I don't know if
we should try it or just like where's
lives
on the edge or just the norm Street
Meats
we're not getting sick
[Music]
if there are people eating at them yeah
feel free to go if there's one where
nobody's going do not go well that's
that would just be the end course good
one in general when you're in a a place
that you're not from and you don't know
what to do just follow what the people
who are from there are doing because
like because the chances of it being the
right thing to do are good now if you do
that in the country you're from you
probably suck but if you that's like a
good way to get around again
good good good good uh Point yeah you
know if you're in the country and you're
following people you're sheep if you're
in a Punchy where you don't live you're
not a sheep you're just experiencing it
and I am not following the people in my
country because I'm not a sheep I am
[__] I believe in Jesus why are there
still monkeys go to the if if you
believe in heaven
and go to the zoo and get back to me
dude one time I I'm gonna open this okay
okay thank you for the wow that is
unbelievable how loud it is though you
need to do it in the [__] thing next
time because it's just something can you
get me a water dude thanks
um I was I met this girl in Las Vegas
gonna end in tears no I mean kinda I was
like
you were there I think this was a long
time ago maybe you weren't I don't know
I've been to Vegas a lot dude I'm a
bigger I'm a big roller but it was like
a really long time ago anyway
like we were saying like Ashton was
there yeah yeah
um and uh
met this girl she was like taking us
around to some places I don't even I
remember this okay I don't know if I was
there but I remember this okay and we
kind of like hit it off we were hanging
out we like ended up hanging out just
the two of us a bunch nice and if you
know what I mean at one point uh I don't
know how it came up but evolution came
up and what she said about evolution
it was even worse than saying she
doesn't believe in it and that she
believes something else the way she
phrased it was like I don't know I just
never really like bought into that one
optional buy-in or not it's like you
either think it or you don't I mean
obviously think it because it's
obviously true Revolution thing I'm on
the fence I don't know if we yeah it was
like I don't know if I buy it like
there's still monkeys and it's like I
don't know I never really bought that
one it's like what that one what do you
mean like yeah it's not conspiracy
there's like a whole series of them on
offer and you get to pick and choose
this is not how that works you don't get
to decide for yourself what things to
believe in you just believe in them
oh that's that's [__] I don't
believe in that it's like that is even
though that's wrong that's right better
you're wrong with conviction yeah she's
just a dum-dum yeah honestly it was like
nice to meet you
I'll see you later that's it really yeah
it was gone oh wow yeah I like Dum Dums
so I would have hung out with any dum
dum I hang out with so I mean I like
male or female dumb people are fine but
the way it was just like it was just an
optional thing she posed it as I didn't
like that all right so that's cool uh I
want to talk about well I guess we could
do another thing but I wanted to talk
about
um
the
I talked about this on congratulations I
think the um by the way like And
subscribe leave a comment thank you
it'll be really really nice what's up
with the you said there's
we should do another thing but you said
there's water stores yeah remember we
talked about this yeah yeah on the text
though right it was on the text yeah all
right
because I kind of know about this but I
don't really know about this so do you
want to do this now or what what's up
luxury no okay all you gotta do is
Google I know it's gonna be hard for
Anthony because he doesn't know how to
Google right but if he just sits in
front of his computer opens Google and
writes the word water space spell it
because you know he doesn't store okay
w-a-t-r space
s-t-o-r-e that's all you have to Google
yeah come on dude I'm dead serious bring
it up bring it up bring it up bring it
up up bring it up bring it up hey can
you do this before we even get into it
Kevin
you don't know how to do that box is too
fast say it again I'm like Busta Rhymes
yeah everybody
you know that song Marco everybody wow
okay so water store okay the 10 best
water stores in L.A see dude it's a
bunch of them dude I don't understand
this
Beyond O2 alkaline water aqua h2go water
land Fresh Living Watermark what are
these places why are you selling water
go to a store and buy water because
there's water in it you don't need your
own store for water every store has
water Aqua best so far Radio Shack has
water dude everything has a smoke shops
I've ordered Pico water like what are we
doing here in it it's like it's like
it's like alkaline balanced whatever the
hell it is water and I guess it's better
than regular water but like I'm pissed
you know
um all right so all right so let's go
into uh the next thing so it's very
weird the water place Chris never seen
those before in my life Chris and
Anthony did either of you know about uh
water stores no okay so that's one no
Chris did you know about water stores no
no you know what why don't any of you
know about water that's the weirdest
part about it what I didn't know about
it this is what I want people to comment
under the thing did you know there were
water stores here's the thing because I
had no idea here's my question though
which is even crazier like why are there
so many who's going to these this is
keeping them in business this is the
whole point if I don't know about them
neither do they
I'm just using me because I'm me okay if
I don't know about them
and there's so many yeah how are they in
business I don't know about them okay be
like okay I just don't go but there are
so many I've seen at least 12 just
living in La throughout the course of my
life like that's a lot that's like more
than the amount of McDonald's I've seen
you know what I mean
yeah
all right we know it's absolutely
okay all right it's mantle Maya
Matt Chris what's good studied magic
yep you're gonna know
um so I have a question for you guys
commenting your significant other after
she does something that she's already
done and you've already give her a
compliment on it right so for example my
wife loves to reverse park into a
parking spot cool and she did it
perfectly the first time cool so now I'm
like awesome job great job but every
time she does it she's almost kind of
looking over to me anticipating for me
to compliment her again and again and
again but after a while it's got to stop
right what is your take okay I I hear
you I feel you here's what I think great
submission it's really cute that she
does that first of all it's cute when
people are like didn't I do good like
that's just a cute thing especially
within
Partnerships relationships like this
okay uh like intimate relationships I
mean your hat and
um
it's annoying to be on the other side of
it because you don't want to be like I
gotta do this feel pressure yeah I'm
gonna do this again we did this so all
you got to do is like
in that case for instance something
really simple and fun for yourself to do
so it's not like a chore you can just be
like this
you know what I'm saying something that
is like at least not like oh wow you
don't have to pretend like oh great job
that's annoying honestly rate it every
time she parties yeah yeah make it a
game make it like a a competition with
previous times that she's done it that's
that's a better idea
lost your mind just on the radio on a
radio ten four okay put it away put it
away Christmas is fun out put it away
okay so the thing is I had it I had my
phone so it's fine
um yeah I think that's a good good thing
a good question I also think though that
um
I don't know that's interesting I will
say though if you were going get like
if it's what if it if it's something
that they did once that they do once
like say hey I tried painting check this
out wow that's very good to follow that
up a few days later and be like I was
just thinking about that painting you
really did a really good job with that
painting that
would give you mileage man oh sure yeah
okay you probably just gotta probably
getting BJ's out there was you if you
did that you know what I mean getting
into no nitpicky fights for like three
months yep yeah gotta keep thinking
about that painting you did and then
just keep doing it well for years she
might question it and be like are you
[__] with me like be like this
what's up remember that painting you did
in 2018 four years later it just was
gorgeous
so transparent you know uh all right
cool next one
hey guys my name is
oh no no no no it paused not happy hey
guys my name is
hi my name is
no dude
woke up in the desert woke up in the
desert has no idea where it is you gotta
leave it you gotta leave whatever's
happening in because what Matt did was
great he's a Nicholas Cage character
dude I want it to work I want to do that
no wait I want it to work
I need to be a boss like that no way I
need to be in which it is not working is
pissing me off so much it's not that
it's not playing at the start hey guys
my name is
[Applause]
I don't know
wait why would this one be not working
oh
so transparent I don't know
hey guys my name is cesa I'm a drummer
in the Nashville area
my problem is that people don't believe
me when I say that or they say I don't
look oh my God even in grad school my
classmates would feel the need to
explain really basic concepts to me I
could be on my own gig and I get asked
if I'm helping the drummer move
equipment and on multiple occasions I'll
be like sitting at my drums and the
sound tech will ask me if I know where
the drummer is
well wow next month is a really big
International Conference for percussion
and inevitably every year I run into
people who ask if I'm a singer for some
reason or who assume I'm their
accompanying a boyfriend and still after
all these years I don't know how to
respond to any of those people any
suggestions
I mean they just have a bit like dude
obviously like what they're saying is
you're you're pretty you know there's
not much they're being sexist but I mean
like dude if it was a no if it was a
chick that looked like a a dude
they wouldn't probably wouldn't happen
as much well no here's what it is there
are very few visible female drummers
which is what you're saying right
especially like but here's the third one
here's the other thing that this is
unfortunate for you in particular I
would imagine a lot of that like maybe
not more than half but a good amount of
that is definitely guys just trying to
talk to you
um I think it's more of a sexist thing
no it it is that but it's it's like it
is that
what is that from again it's from the
Tupac
interview where they're like what is it
he says
you can't say that on the podcast oh
okay okay okay well I can't yeah I think
we can't no no but we could play it
right is the m word or something yeah
yeah okay cool anyway but you [__]
say that yeah Tupac anymore but he can
say that he is that it is that all he
wants uh interview yeah that's really
just kind of unfortunate but I totally
get I mean that would be anything that
me I have to repeat many times to many
people almost nothing drives me more
crazy than that you know that about me
than having to re oh the thing I said
basically yeah basically just the thing
I said you know uh when I have to repeat
something like I'm doing now again and
again to people over and over it's just
so
maddening and annoying I mean
I'm you you actually kind of I think
usually you don't have the right to be
like
Express anger you know uh but in this
case because it kind of is a bit at
least a bit sexist yeah usually then I I
feel like you kind of can
have a little attitude about it if
you're angry but you probably just want
to minimize the whole thing whole event
as much as possible so like
really just like the most abbreviated
thing you you can think of to do the
better so
in every case that's different though
because they're saying it in different
ways so maybe the only thing you could
have to do is uh just whenever they say
something that alludes to the fact that
you can't possibly be the drummer just
say
I'm a drummer
okay a lot of words to just say to come
but like but like her version of
whatever she wants but like
um are you waiting for your boyfriend
where's the drama I'm a drummer
you don't sing
like that's just a weird thing to do all
right so which is what you did that's
it's just sexist which is you know
sometimes sexism is you know like that's
not that worst sexism but it's like
annoying as [__] especially if it's
happening over and over again but
there's not that many female hot chick
drummers that are visible
well in fact I can only think of like
less than one handful I know zero but I
don't know music at all right okay yeah
so Chris you know music can you think of
any high profile female drummers
there is uh like I can think of the most
famous ones is a woman named Sheila E
is a drummer yeah she's a Nails wow and
but could you do this
wow so annoying that thing
know what it is yes how about that guy
in the the local band that you love so
much Marco the guy playing Sharp Dressed
Man oh yeah that's that's the cool
drummer guy when he goes like this with
the twisty stick oh can we play it or no
we're gonna play that on luxury as well
okay we'll plan on luxury dude
what's more annoying air drums or air
guitar
air drums
that's the tough one though air drums
air guitar though eardrums is worse an
end
any kind of drums unless you're playing
which is also very annoying because it's
so loud
drums are cool dude how much does this
play the drums well are unbelievably I
agree agree agree but how about how
Uncle Mike is always like you know if
Nick wants to if or not nick uh
our Uncle Mike is very eager to share
his drums very vast drum knowledge
knowledge I got two drums in the guitar
why does he have two why oh well one is
a real set and the other one is the
silent one that just is like that only
for you with the headphones on it's like
it sounds very quiet yeah I mean my my
son Kevin will be like yeah they'll be
like what kind of chicken you want he
was like oh give me a breast and a
drumstick drumsticks
so excited you know your Uncle Mike sent
his other drum set to my house I knew
that yeah that's right see yeah no I
know he was like that with you yeah he
was like oh you played he was so happy
when you learned Chris play drums don't
even listen to anything with drums in it
around Uncle Mike because he will give
you a drumstick don't mention drums
don't mention interest in music he will
sing he's like those Saudi Arabian guys
that where you can't compliment the [__]
they have to just give it to you yeah
like we're like oh this is a cool camel
and they'll be like it's yours that's
Uncle Mike with drums yeah yeah you
listen to Phil Collins and you you
listen to [__] sister studio and you
just go like this
you're like this I got jumped in the
garage I got two I'll give you one oh
yeah he's like uh yeah he's very eager
to share his drums yeah literally not
just his knowledge about drums but his
actual drums yeah he's willing to ship
to you very generous if you accept I
mean most generous about as generous as
you yeah as you can he is a great man
and very generous and wants to give you
his drum sets yeah he always trying to
give you his drums
um so anyway yeah that's good for that
that will be in Nashville come on see me
in Nashville chrysalia.com
so to finish that advice though
come up with something that is very very
brief and very to the point and then say
nothing more when they inquire more all
you are trying to con get across is that
yes you are a drummer and the
conversation stops there it's so
annoying to have to do that over and
over again and then explain why someone
who looks like you would play it's so
annoying I'd love for her to send a
video of
[Music]
Okay so
what was the name Zara what was this
girl's name anyway
I forgot your name I apologize send us a
video of you doing that but for real
thank you we'll play it on the next
episode oh we gotta play the thing on
Lifeline luxury I can't wait to watch
the thing on Lifeline it's my one of my
favorite videos Sharp Dressed Man dude
okay her name is so so yeah Sami Sosa so
I'm in love with this so it was that
loud so so loud that's
Coco who's the Sosa Sammy Sosa going
going
is white now
he's [__] oh yeah yeah he is does he
have Villages now
does he have little with what the [__]
is how do you Vitiligo okay
vitology the the Pearl Jam vehicle
Mortensen vehicle dude I'm in love with
Sammy Sosa wow look how white look at
him now dude hey dude if you're like
that click the one bro Anthony it is
unreal you wouldn't click the picture
with the [__]
[__] hat dude he's got the [__] had
a lips manless and he [__] goes and I
wouldn't click something out
unbelievable dude I have a problem
Google image something for everyone to
see and click on that role he's got a
[__] flat top Dick Tracy with a
chrome Hearts matching shirt and this
guy clicks on him in a [__] regular
suit with his hair this is regular hair
unbelievable dude look at him that's
weird what happened poor guy what is
that yeah
but what is the thing that he has
Vitiligo I don't think is it it looks
like something else because it's so like
all the way across his face I have
Vitiligo
what's that
dude wow that's bad huh well it's okay
you know yeah
denied having it okay maybe he doesn't
have it maybe he just has been inside
since he retired and then he came to
that Premiere with the red hat on
it's he's just like this it's time to go
out
after 11 years what the [__] dude
honestly I wouldn't be surprised if that
was something to do with the steroid use
right dude I read an article at Sports
Illustrated Ken cabinet remember him uh
third Bishop for the Astros yeah and the
Padres he was a big it was an All-Star
third disease right did he oh no that
was he was a big alcoholic right I think
he was anyway I don't know but he's a
steroid nut like according to him he did
it more than even anybody he knew and he
was a first-hand account of what stars
do to his body he said
that his sack
balls was yeah his ball sack was well no
because it was just a sack because his
balls he did so much storage the balls
went inside his body like he was a
[__] baby Insider Mother's Day he was
hiding him yeah hiding from the steroids
dude but they made his but his sack was
just a swinging nothing in it fly in the
wind nothing in his sack dude
okay
going going go on yeah Chris Berman was
the best dude
a chicken
but that's what he would do I know
so dumb dude he had the best like God he
would be such a how much he would be so
memed now dude how yeah he would be how
much does he have a an extreme right
wing [__] uh Show podcast on like
valutainment I don't want to be like
this but I think he might be dead I
think Christopher might have died I
think he's alive you're saying he's gone
yeah he yeah dude he went back back back
on
from the dead okay
[Laughter]
dude he's he's a king this guy's a he
was incredible can you do a [__]
backpack backpack video of him can you
play one we'll do that on on that one we
could do that on luxury right yeah but
the thing he got mad at someone on air
we should watch that on luxury dude yeah
remember that what was that he got
really mad doesn't he look like a guy
that gets so red-faced he gets so red
Chris Berman one going going Gonzalez
right that was so many good ones dude so
many good ones Andre bad moon risen oh
dude wait what's that Andre Rison was a
big I know that but what is it Bad Moon
Rising oh bad moon yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh wow there's a bad man like uh
Jamaican No No Bad Moon Rising yeah
he was the best okay yeah yeah
hey Chris hey Matt Chris been a long
time fan forever true baby I've seen you
in Pittsburgh I can't wait going with my
brothers
be awesome Matt you're awesome love your
personality love you two together
um I have two old rows myself so cute
interactions is just so relatable and
just awesome I love it
um but I'll keep it quick kind of so
fresh out of college I just started this
job I'm barely two months in and uh
right before I accepted the job offer I
asked if there were any locations closer
uh to me
uh that we're hiring positions because
right now that job is an hour away so
I'm driving two hours for work every day
which is a little taxing
uh they said that
there weren't any other closer locations
available so I said okay I started the
job and then two weeks into the job they
post a place 20 minutes away from me
with the exact same job description
exact same title which kind of pissed me
off a bit so I emailed HR yeah and was
like hey can I transfer basically and I
did it professionally I've been very
professional this entire time
and they talked to my P the two PMS from
each region and the guy above them they
approve it they just said that I have to
get a replacement uh before a transfer
which makes sense however next week is a
new employee starting out and may I
remind you that I'm only two months
since I'm basically a new employee as
well yeah
um my PM comes up to me today and says
I don't know if he counts as your
replacement
um this sucks now I'm lost I'm so lost
nothing makes sense anymore why is he
not my replacement why can't I move
um
maybe they're still figuring stuff out
uh just let me know what you think what
I should do who I should talk to am I
being crazy for making a big deal out of
this
I don't think I am at all but let me
know on his way
talk to come with big scissors
hi I'm here look with with
big cheers
why is it come [__] it's come with big
scissors it's like bring along big
scissors well because it's funnier to
have a sexual deviation is it then arts
and crafts Indian I guess I do just big
scissors is the guy's name you know what
I mean he's like yeah he's like no no
he's the creative one no come with big
scissors is the guy's name that yeah I
get it now but yeah okay okay
thinking about sex
oh my god oh
cutting a bush because they're outside
they're always outside their Indian oh
okay
racist when did it happen where remember
when we were kids everyone was like it's
Native American it's not Indian Now
American Indian is right when did that
happen words are nothing
on acid
words are nothing dude an acid they
really aren't though oh no we're but
they just choose
language changes over time and it's easy
to look at what a word meant then and a
word what a word meant now and think oh
this is all arbitrary [__] words are
nothing that's another way of saying it
okay very quick way of saying it okay
but it's less nuanced and specific than
what I'm saying because it doesn't
matter at all
remember
now you have to say trans person up
until [__]
you know
yeah but six years ago people just but
language said the thing that rhymes with
Granny but but language evolves
and also a transvestite is not what a
trans person is people said that because
yeah right words but anyway it doesn't
matter my point is language evolves it
is annoying when there's like a top-down
effort to make it change language
naturally evolves and that's just a
thing that happens throughout the course
of people's lives but what's frustrating
and difficult is when people are like no
what it's called now is this but all I'm
saying is I thought Indian was like a
derogatory term but now it's now it's
back and that's I don't know what you're
supposed to say is from what I
understand I don't know anything dude
I'm always confused yeah yeah I don't
know I just um that's why you can't play
the game
well I just wish it was easier to know
which one is the right way to sit
because like people are saying the wrong
thing now it's like it's hard to even
tell if it's that I don't know oh [__]
here's what it should be you say the
thing and they go you can't say that
anymore you go like oh I didn't know
you're right because that's usually the
case yeah yeah yeah for sure yeah
because I I've been in that situation
where I say oh you can't say that and
they're like that's happened to me it's
happened to me you're like yeah you
can't say that and I was like
since when right and they were like a
few years and I was like oh I guess
because I never say it you know so I'm
like right right I had no idea so right
you talk about Indians actually never
mind I don't want to get in t-r-a-n-n oh
that yeah specifically I said that you
know with like four people around
I would know not to say it now but this
was years ago oh I see it it was years
ago got it got it and they go you can't
say that and I was like really right
yeah you can't okay you can't yeah but
but but 10 years ago nobody knew that is
my point correct about well six years
ago yeah and people were like you can't
say that still so hung up I had no idea
so it's fine I've moved on such an
accident you know all right cool we're
doing more we're done
you guys have a schedule you know yeah
okay all right well that was a good
episode a lot of laughing a lot of
loving a lot of coming together
um okay yeah we could do a Lifeline
luxury actually right now because I have
some good stories to tell so come on
over to Lifeline luxury Lifeline luxury
uh uh patreon.com Lifeline luxury sign
up baby we love it patronize us get over
there and patronize us we'll give you
the goods we got the goods all you got
to do is go over there and sign up baby
and I'll be in uh your city
chrysalia.com yes dude uh you want a
one-on-one with me matelie.com you want
the merch go to lifelinemerch.com like
And subscribe to this video uh you want
to make a submission do that uh and at
the link below and I think that's it
thank you
hello hello
[Music]